when I was a child I used to eat a whole
platter of nachos for a snack then I'd
go and eat a whole chicken fingers and
fries dinner and still have room for
dessert and a bedtime snack
oh these days not so much that you just
hate your childhood self well rather
than loathing my younger self I thought
we'd get back at it at trying to find a
holy grail of metabolism boosters in
previous videos we've covered things
like coconut oil weight training and
chili peppers no magic pills yet guys
but don't worry I'm on it let's do this
t-too plays cattiness be said to have
metabolism boosting properties but
researchers are also saying that the
catechin antioxidants may have
thermogenic properties as well then we
love teks it's a calorie free
alternative to soda or juice but I
wouldn't OD on the stuff expecting to
see a huge spike in your metabolism
fiber s0 plays yeah okay so this one's
kind of set I've seen a lot of
sensationalized blogs out there claiming
that fiber will boost your metabolism
but the research just does not support
this theory at all I am pretty hardcore
about recommending fiber because it's
been shown to be so much more satiating
so you actually can eat less but the
research actually suggests that it may
decrease post meal metabolism slightly
now I wouldn't get all hyped up on this
either way these are really small sample
sizes we're talking about but the bottom
line is eat fiber to feel full not to
boost your metabolism heat when you're
hungry and often the replays research
suggests that eating small meals every
few hours is a good way to keep that
fuel burning longer all day long so
start to really turning to your body
and listening for those cues of hunger
and satiety and then of course nourish
your body accordingly trust me once you
start to ask yourself if you're hungry
enough to eat and then feeding that
hunger those hunger signals will become
a lot more louder clearer getting enough
sleep is zero player
ah yes another stinker researchers
consistently linking poor sleep to a
higher risk of obesity and food cravings
but the research on metabolism is just
not there in fact I actually have one
small study that found that shorter
sleepers or people who aren't sleeping
as much actually burned an extra 100
calories per day but guys that's
probably because they're not sleeping
they're doing other things like moving
and walking and eating having said that
guys you're probably gonna
overcompensate for those calories burned
with a midnight poutine let's just be
honest we clearly need more research on
the table in sleep but in the meantime
guys don't skimp out on your shut-eye
Wow Wow got it oh we need more magic
must be a mystical unicorn out there
that can poop out some miracle excrement
that will turn back the hands of time or
maybe a whale with some kind of mystical
Oh nope not touching that but anyways
guys don't worry I am gonna find
whatever that quick-fix magic pill is
and you are gonna want to experience it
with me so be sure to subscribe to my
channel so you don't miss out on it also
leave me a comment below with whatever
kind of metabolism booster do you want
to find out about like this video share
with your friends and I'll see you next
time on Abbey's kitchen